[Music]
[Laughter]
congratulations is brought to you by the
cash dang bro up here at the frickin log
cabin the log cave-in bro this guy lives
on a hill man I would never build
something up here I can't even tell you
where we guys are I am in I had to drive
here you know I got it uber actually
they got a new thing out here in LA
uber twink and you got a sexy little
dude who you know hadn't really made a
you know all of the choices in his own
hardened in his own sexuality and he
drove me up here and broke I met uh
Chris D'Elia right here what is this
[ __ ] Spanish bro
congratulations get the [ __ ] out dude
this guy is rich bro I [ __ ] sprained
my ankle stepped in a pot of gold
walking down the hallway on accident the
neighbours bro I look happy April Fool's
let me start right there I don't know
what happened man I just woke up here
it's like a time warp and and I'm gonna
be the guide today I got controls over
everything when we look at these let me
hear this thing right there Oh what is
that dude somebody spilled a milk uh-oh
wanted a baby still down man well what's
up babies my baby
daddy song who wants a little breast
milk Oh spilt some well steal some new
good to be your man it is rich out here
bro I went outside and got [ __ ]
hitting the face by a checkbook bro
somebody [ __ ] two dudes rolled up
white guys out here and [ __ ] beat me
with a couple of hard [ __ ]
bang beans dude one of his neighbors
Rapunzel okay Aunt Jemima the third bro
rumor Wilson that dude's got [ __ ]
rich neighbors probably went across the
street knocked on the door it's a Wells
Fargo bro with a pool in the back in
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ] teaching it out here
what is that I think this is this is
what Chris plays probably when he takes
out your in zipper Danny's limonada baby
calm down baby's stepdad here good to be
here man
first we want to dispel a couple of
rumors about Chris Oh Lia first of all a
lot of people have said those rumors
going around that Chris bought a college
and shut it down bro okay Dunn's a monk
on dumpling mom I heard that that is
true man there's also rumors that Chris
invested three million dollars in
fairness okay and [ __ ] lost it baby
doesn't make a drop a lot of poor
choices by the one and only Chris D'Elia
there's a rumor that Krista Leah's feet
are very small but his shoes are very
big doesn't make Ronald McDonald but
those are just rumors guys let's press
this one what does this do Oh Chris
hearted [ __ ] group of old men to
laugh at his jokes unbelievable we don't
have that we have real laughter
all-natural laughter made out of the
heart good to be here man welcome to
congratulations podcast this podcast
brought to you by the cash app get your
get your cash and press this one Oh
how rich are you
you don't wanna pronounce a letter of
the alphabet guy oh you know the vowels
a e i o and sometimes you bruh
unbelievable guy this guy dude there's
all kinds of magic stuff in here good to
be
happy April Fool's is April you know so
if you haven't been [ __ ] paying
attention guys and now's the time and I
got to tell you some things recently
that have just been pissing me off first
of all uh people are still [ __ ]
drinking milk are you kidding me guy get
something else right let me hit this one
oh wow what is that one Oh somebody
works at a mercantile huh
oh you want a little you want a
half-pint of butter
I got your boo-boo and here's another
one and change it and change it and
change it and change it that one's
pretty good hi bye hi bye bye
it was Japanese hi bye hi bye good to be
here man April Fool's dude I'm in here
in the Chris D'Elia domicile man it's
crazy
butters and [ __ ] Segway or whatever
that other little dog's name are here
man they got him on a weekly least this
week so you know they're up here taking
photos when I'm apparently had a had a
stroke and had to replace it so we're on
I think on the Segway the second that's
Chris doing yardwork you did a $6,000
plant out in the front yard there's a
price tag still on it on thank you let's
press this one
I like this little bit of Johnny Cash
huh welcome guys to the log cabin and
daddy's here to help you do some sucking
in [ __ ] and in case you don't have
anything to do with your downtime today
no it's nice man it's nice to come you
know over here to Chris Delia's domicile
I'm happy that he let us in here
congratulations podcast decent podcast
probably one of the top six or 700
podcasts out there you may have heard of
it if you haven't you're first-time
listener you came because I'm here Wow
free black friends when you press that
one huh unbelievable so good
unbelievable what is this one you coud
yeah cool yeah that's good I like this
[Music]
you don't even hate Chris Lee you just
got a couple of [ __ ] buttons I don't
even know how to talk about man I feel
so out of place here a little bit man
I mean everything here is nice dude they
got real wood on the table you know they
don't have a lot of these we've had bed
bugs in our studio recently so we've got
a couple of issues going on and actually
been a blessing to be here cuz we needed
to get some extermination going on in
our side of the net so um I am happy to
have that but it's nice to be here in
the 2-time runner-up TF ATK guest of the
year studio you know you don't know what
it's like usually you got to come down
from the hills to [ __ ] spend time you
know with the second level with the
second tier but at this time we had to
drive up here man they had two unicorns
in the yard some got shot one right in
front of us for no reason he says he was
sick a lot of crazy stuff going on up
here real art uh Samuel Rembrandt the
seventieth was in the hallway painting
when I walked in like there's a lot of
[ __ ] going on here the mirrors here at
Chris's when you walk and you look in
them it's him looking back at you
you don't [ __ ] you want your
reflection you better [ __ ] go down
the hills guys
doesn't matter I'm red flags and you got
to get the real [ __ ] boy turn around
yeah if you want a [ __ ] you want to
look at yourself turn around and go home
okay cuz daddy's here to breastfeed the
[ __ ] babies making milk with my big
what else boy Dillon then this is good
man and we got my boy one higher here
what's up Papa how are you today good
and so what do you notice is different
today about the studio just me okay cool
so and what do i do what should i do
right now if i'm chris i gonna mine okay
I'll bring up a YouTube okay I'll bring
up a YouTube guy alright I had [ __ ]
had to spend the whole weekend with
[ __ ] Leno Qi who doesn't know how to
walk correctly and if you've seen him on
my Instagram walking [ __ ] go back to
[ __ ] walk school okay can you bring
up the YouTube video of the there's an
african-american gentleman going in
number two and there's a older white
gentleman looking under the YouTube
under the stall at him and he bust that
guy that [ __ ] straight up duty lurker
let's see that man right here that's it
right there got a toilet yeah oh no no
that is something else boy that's the
dark arts nope not it it's a man you got
a Google I think whole broad can't look
at that guy's thighs anymore like dude
I'd rather way rather blow a gun and
probably look at his thighs for you know
more than a couple seconds especially if
he's like has very hairy thighs we need
a man doing duty and white man caught
looking
no that's a cartoon who made that huh
yeah guys well while he's figuring that
out dude I'm gonna tell you about a
story it happened to me so one time I'm
in Seattle okay some of you might have
[ __ ] heard of it
and I was up there and I had ayan I went
to the year to the restroom right and
they had a man in there and I don't it
was kind of a darker-skinned gentleman
you know and he was vending skittles and
cigarettes over there about a sink he
was running shop and so I had to do in
numbered number two you know and a
straight up a good you know and one of
those old boys you know you know a thick
urine out of the back and so I walked
into the stall right well right after
that some dude came in and oh right
after I went into the stall the guy
working in the restroom came and banged
on the door and he's like don't worry
man I got your back and I'm like he got
my back I mean [ __ ] know this guy
right I was trying to use the potty well
next thing you know dude some guy comes
in and he wants to maybe do drugs or he
also has to use the toilet so he starts
pulling on the door right well the guy
I'm in there so the guy the bouncer you
know the candy balancer the [ __ ] bouncer
whatever the guy works in the bathroom
is called comes up to the door and says
hey man chill out that's my boy in there
and I'm not his boy I didn't even
[ __ ] look the man denies I don't
[ __ ] know him
well anyway the guy who's trying to get
into the toilet starts talking [ __ ] the
guy who's trying to like who's like the
bouncer out there the [ __ ] bouncer right
bro they get into a [ __ ] fight right
and I can't [ __ ] if two people are
[ __ ] beating each other near me so
now I'm all locked up right people come
in a ton of people come in I have to go
out and talk to the Foley's probably I
have no idea what happened and it was
all because of that man was trying to
just really have my back while I took
[Music]
turn around yeah that's what I'm saying
when a guy comes by me next time you
want to [ __ ] be a [ __ ] bouncer when
I'm in the toilet
turn around yes yes oh that's Brady
that's Bertie Stevens isn't it oh okay
okay let's go to this video right here
is this it okay good well this episodes
really [ __ ] hit the skids
I am what's going on babies you know I
was just in uh you know I had to do a
couple of shows in Mogadishu for the
[ __ ] King of Siam last night and he
tried to pay me in [ __ ] sand oh
that's it right there let's go to the
beginning of this one this is a great
video where there's a herbivorous go oh
it's playing right now he's just looking
if you're listening to this on audio man
you probably have turned it off me
in that video it's called man catch this
guy looking under his stall alright and
there's a there's a man on the on the
tool then you see me like he could he
sounds like he could be african-american
but he might not be it could be a white
goddess pretend to be african-american
[Music]
there you go slam that guy and so if and
then he catches a [ __ ] guy who looks
like the grandson of lug and Johnny
monopolies that the owner of the
boardgame peeking under the urinal stall
and he really catches him so you got to
go check that out man anyway
what else do we do what else can I do
now
whampire oh dude let's talk about lonoa
the [ __ ] Fred
Fox tone of comedy okay this guy dude
what I saw him [ __ ] reading Joe he
has Snapple jokes probably ever opened a
Snapple the if you have if you've ever
opened a Snapple then you've heard
[ __ ] my klonoa and his little twink
buddy hot Zachary that goes with him and
hot Zachary's Italian and he's always
saying that he [ __ ] is a manager of a
bunch of boxers and [ __ ] dude but
nobody's ever seen the [ __ ] pockets
bro
unless he's talking about his
undershorts he said he used to work for
Floyd Meriwether bro who the [ __ ] is
Floyd Meriwether the boat captain get
the [ __ ] out of hand
[Music]
that's copy written I'm sure let's do
one more there you go
somebody just bought off [ __ ] hub of
butter in the 1800s okay guys so what do
we do now man are we done I feel like we
covered it man let me talk more about
somebody uh-oh guys if one more [ __ ]
person says hey man as I'm flying out of
Toledo with Bank with a [ __ ] chase
ATM under my arm if one more guy hits me
on Instagram says hey man when you're
performing in Toledo [ __ ] yes - I don't
like does that [ __ ] I don't like I don't
like conch yeah good conch in that guy
cuz I can't stand that [ __ ] okay what
else when are we done yet all right I
brought a couple of guests today guys
and I want to let you know who they are
who are they oh I brought some [ __ ]
guests that I brought producer Nick a
rear premature Nick man and he was born
early even though he denies it so he's a
[ __ ] premature birth denier and then
we got [ __ ] a little Johnny brunt and
I don't if you ever met a little Johnny
they're gonna mean that guy is like 16
years old bro you know he's obviously up
here running leg for a lot of these rich
guys at night but during the day he
comes down the hill and [ __ ] helps us
book some
[Music]
so you got to know what's up babies and
if you're not [ __ ] and sucking back
at the crib babies then I don't know
what you're doing okay
cuz I'm serving 100% [ __ ] gunk yeah
I'm serving a hundred percent [ __ ]
gunk
yes gunk and we got little Jaya aunty up
here in Cheyenne he looks like kind of
like I'm have you ever seen somebody
from the eighteen hundred's that used to
do powerlifting you know before they
were actually strong and they just wrote
really high numbers on the weights and
they would hold them in the air
that's [ __ ] baby je ne dude looks
like about a [ __ ] 24 year old 8 month
old bro beautiful guy too and uh and I'd
probably drink some of his blood if
we're on tap what now what do we do Oh
last concert you went to I think
probably Smashing Pumpkins you have no
concert prob about 20 years I want to
smash some pumpkins one time and I fell
asleep in the audience so and they
didn't smash any pumpkins dude it was a
bald-headed guy who looked like he had a
vitamin D deficiency it seemed like
crying about something to some pretty
sweet riffs so when I heard that I said
turn around yeah that's what I said and
this one yeah you got [ __ ] slam boy
okay welcome to Denny's where Chris
jokes around about Denny's even though
people get shot there and murdered there
everyday in a syrup fight can we bring
that up there was actually just another
three people were shot inside of a
Denny's pretending to be [ __ ] Chris
D'Elia
turn around yeah you coud you could not
[ __ ] many people go to Denny's and
shoot people Chris okay hot slam hots I
am
yeah that's what I'm saying and also
this so yeah and so the last time that I
went to a show I was a Tom it was
Smashing Pumpkins so it's been a while
even though actually I did go see the
Goo Goo Dolls 6 times I forgot about
that and they're good man even though
the drummer looks like the penguin from
one of the Batman movies what else can
we talk about just do the podcast like
you would do yours okay thank you oh
yeah I went to the dermatologist today
man and I thought I had skin cancer
right and the guy it was a [ __ ] rich
guy man and I'll tell you this dude the
second I see a rich guy I don't give a
[ __ ] what he's telling me you know
because the whole time I'm just wishing
he had cancer and I'm just thinking go
[ __ ] yourself buddy and that's when I
just turn around and [ __ ] yes get in
an uber that's what I saying because
oh Jesus Christ so yeah I went there man
he said I have a malignant growth or a
benign growth on my face
whatever one doesn't kill you and he
offered to burn it off with a hot pen
he's like [ __ ] that bro if I'm gonna
have somebody burned something off of my
face with a hot [ __ ] I'm gonna [ __ ]
go home and do it for free
so that was pretty much it what else man
I went in a coffee bean today and there
was that homeless guy in there and look
I love the homeless you know if they
shaped up a little I let a couple of
them stay at my place but um this guy
had two canes right and he was just
playing the whole like you know Vietnam
veteran but he couldn't pick Vietnam off
a mat bro if you gave him one map and
only Vietnam was on the map and stopped
and spotted him the at Nam this dude
couldn't find [ __ ] Vietnam bro and he
had two canes man and that kind of broke
my heart a little bit what else do we do
now man
are we done no all right guys I do want
to let you know that this like an
amazing episode has been brought to you
by me undies and I don't know if you've
ever put your crotch into something soft
you know but I mean this is like
wrapping a couple of newborn twins
around you jump me undies man I'm in him
right now and I wish they were a
two-seater cuz I didn't fight somebody
yeah you probably spent about 90% of
your life and underwear I don't you
[ __ ] so don't you think it's don't
you think you owe it to yourself to make
sure you're wearing the softest undies
in town that's why I only wear me undies
me undies uses the coveted micro motile
fabric which is a full three times
softer than cotton not only we feel your
look like your loins are being hugged by
joy itself but me undies gives you
multiple style options for both men and
women men can now try the new boxer
brief with fly which is the same great
cut as box or brief but now with an
added option for guys you prefer to go
through the gate verse over the fence
wow I like that me undies is also the
go-to for the softest loungewear on the
plane
it hang out in there super comfy lounge
fans and onesie yep me undies makes it
onesie and they're incredible you get
15% off a pair of the most comfortable
undies you'll ever put on think about
your ol underwear now quit thinking
about them to get 15% of your first pair
free shipping and 100% satisfaction
guarantee go to me undies dot-com slash
Congrats that's me undies dot-com /
congrats and I'm gonna read another one
also quip one of the most important
things we do for our health everyday is
brushing arts yeah yet most of us don't
do it properly quip is a better
electronic toothbrush created by
dentists and designers succomb Franklin
Lloyd writing your mouth
turnaround quip was designed to make
brushing your teeth more simple
affordable and even enjoyable get gentle
enough on your sensitive gums with
sensitive sonic vibrations it's like
taking your friggin mouth to NASA people
brush too hard you ever see that God has
beaten his teeth with a friggin
toothbrush bro who is that guy that's
nobody
[Music]
so why up to 90% of us don't brush for a
full two minutes and don't clean evenly
you've seen those unclean oohs uneven
clean chicks running around with that
gutter mouth a multi-use cover mounts to
your mirror and unmount to slide over
your bristles for on-the-go brushing you
want to run and brush do it you want to
be the freaking Carl Lewis of clean gums
you got a chance quip decluttered your
sink or cabinet and makes traveling with
an electric toothbrush easier brush
heads are automatically delivered on a
dentist recommended schedule every three
months for just five dollars quit
thinking about how clean your teeth are
gonna be and just get it done three out
of four of us use bristles that are old
worn-out and ineffective
some people even use a mop quip is one
of the first electric toothbrushes
accepted by the American Dental
Association and asked thousands of
verified five-star reviews I personally
I love quit for the automatic refills
you don't have to think about when
you're gonna get that fresh bristle in
you go to the house BAM it's in the
mailbox but out your teeth are clean
that's why I love quit and that's why
they're backed about over 20,000 dental
professionals qyp starts at just $25 and
if you go to get quick calm slash pen
grants right now you get your first
refill pack for free that's right babies
with a quip electric toothbrush that's
your first refill pack free at get quip
dot-com / Congrats
thank you guys very much for supporting
the podcast oh man now what do you do
order post mates or something I don't
even know can we do that
what are we doing yeah I'm not that
hungry man what do they have here I bet
to eat there's nothing to eat here oh
that's crazy this is a chef that comes
here I've seen odd well the guy yeah
there was a couple of chefs hats being
washed in the laundry that's all there
were for chef hats in there like Rosie
no man I'm just happy to be here today
you know Chris is if you look at Chris
from far away you're like jesus [ __ ]
christ dude what's going on over there
you know that guy looks malnourished but
tall and athletic but if you get up
close to him you see that first of all
the guy has some more ribs than anybody
I don't if you ever seen yells daddy
with the shirt off but the guy has do it
I got eight ribs right Chris has
probably rode no joke seventy six ribs
dude
like he's uh you know you ever get one
of those fishes at the arm like when
you're on vacation then
descaled or whatever and they give you
that fish then they got ah and it's got
all the bones in it that's like ham man
but he's got a big heart too he's a very
long heart too like if he dies bro he
wait five people could probably get a
heart transplant from him you know the
guys [ __ ] deep on the aorta swell
what is this is this is from his
Instagram and he does boxers it's a
bathing suit huh
Wow he's pretty strong huh or his legs
nice have you seen his legs in person
very skinny I could see that yeah he
doesn't have everything perfect he
definitely could use some different legs
here's a lot of facial hair and his face
around his chin it looks like you ever
seen after a fire goes over a hill and
they put it out he has that he has that
very fire growth you know like that
Malibu post fire kind of stubble
he's very erotic though his eyes he has
got that he's got that he's got that you
know he's got that David Blaine you know
you look at him and next thing you know
he's [ __ ] pulling a rabbit out of
your ass but I'm happy to be here in his
home today man you know this is probably
I'm trying to think of some nice homes
that I've been in I had to go to over
the David Spade's one time and watch an
episode of The Bachelor and he made me
sit in front of him on the couch while
he sat behind me in a regular chair
which is very interesting one time I
went to a one-year-olds birthday party
at Perry Farrell's house and he was the
lead singer at Jane's Addiction and he
took me to like a bookcase and read to
me all the titles of all the books on
the bookcase for pretty much no reason
I'm talking 300 bucks dude just the type
looks like ever so he was definitely
probably gonna relapse I'm guessing what
else man a friend of mine got a [ __ ]
one time on top of a restaurant and from
Jennifer Capriati and then fell through
the glass like a sky window right in the
[ __ ] kitchen that row that's 15 love
I've ever heard of it what else happened
here right when I got into town in LA
one time I
[Music]
you know uh who's that guy you got that
Mount Rushmore kind of head kind of a
mixed guy Tracy Morgan he um I saw him
with no shirt this before he got Walmart
it right before he got hit by Walmart
I saw him chase uh chasing a woman by
the Andaz hotel with a knife and a big
knife - not the kind of knife you really
usually bring on vacation or travel with
you know some people take a blade but he
had a real butchers piece um what else
has happened ma'am this week not much
man I'm going to Phoenix this weekend to
do some shows Oh what else man I'm just
[ __ ] tired dude I wish I had you know
I wish I guess I had a like I'm a sous
or somebody just to like hug me really
hard sometimes yeah that's pretty much
about it man what else has been going on
you know I was thinking yesterday about
uh about sinkholes man and how they're
[ __ ] starting to act up you know
remember they didn't have them when I
was young how to wish him well you had
to go to a specific area if you wanted
to fall down into the [ __ ] earth you
know but now Mother Nature's starting to
[ __ ] in and change it yeah she's
starting to change it bro she's starting
to [ __ ] clap back at [ __ ]
she's sick of people walking on her back
and taking advantage of her growing corn
on her and growing a dope on her people
are now growing opiates here in America
and uh and so she's starting to act up
she's starting to open her mouth you
know and and that's really what a
sinkhole is man imagine you and you and
your buddy are [ __ ] split in a pack
of Skittles
now imagine both y'all are [ __ ] dead
that's a sinkhole brother you know and
that's how they operate all right Chris
what can we go into oh and there was a
sinkhole right there look at that
dooty member quicksand econo when I was
younger he's talking quicksand and they
never had any of it you know a bunch of
[ __ ] but that's a real sinkhole boy
that's mother nature starting to swallow
dude and that's when it gets crazy
I mentioned laying on the ground with
your dick out and then Mother Nature
just [ __ ] hit you with that sinkhole
bro you try not to come dude dare you
dare you not to just bust straight into
the [ __ ] seventh circle of hell what
else could be you have any other good
sinkholes you can show me please sir oh
here's one right there and that's
beautiful and a lot of more artistic man
a lot of them are very round you know
perfectly round they call it okay let's
get into some segments oh yeah I went on
hot ones man I'll talk about that being
on hot ones it was you know I thought
they would have more spice there I
thought the spice was kind of I thought
they would have more spice and the spice
I thought I think they should dip the
wing into the spice dude I really I've
really been burnt out at a um I went to
a um hooters and where Anthony Davis
actually knocked the gallop over there
by Hooters off or in the West Bank in
New Orleans and they have a child but
but what I'm saying is this dude that I
went there and got really burned out one
time at a party with some buddies and
they have some serious heat over there
by Hooters man so I felt like that was a
hotter experience than when I went on
hot ones but I felt like that man was
really nice Sean you know they had a
yeah Sean Evans very nice man I went and
met up with him the night after for
pizza room-temperature foods and it was
a it was a lot more chill and so that
was nice I got some media is like a
fiance I think she's Italian and they
were you know getting along when I saw
them so huh
she's a Laker girl dang boy you know but
anybody could be a Laker girl now man
it's so diverse I mean they're getting
so diverse they're looking really for
men
or just anybody who's never even looked
at their crotch basically and just you
know just sits down and stands up to pee
at the same time so yeah a beautiful guy
right there Sean Evans so that was a
nice time man yeah I don't know if
that's the girl or not but she looked
nice though oh wow so she looked real
beautiful what else is going on man talk
yeah it was good man San Jose was good
it was uh it was just tiring man I never
did eight shows before and by like the
six the by the seventh and eighth one I
couldn't feel my face man my face
wouldn't respond to some of my desires
so I'd want to smile and it just my
smile couldn't go all the way and I felt
like I couldn't be as happy on stage
because there was just there wasn't
enough like energy left inside of me to
like kind of put out so I felt like I'd
really you know it's just kind of
falling apart at the gills
um what else man dude why don't they
have any like cool doodads or something
in here
what is this you got all of this space
and just nothing
what is this fiber I mean this is crazy
do not contact me with unsolicited
services or offers dude that's half the
fun that's half the fun do when somebody
[ __ ] hit you up in the middle of the
night on Instagram and send you a
SoundCloud link to one of them snoring
new a house beat you know like broke
ain't getting that kind of [ __ ] joy
you know or somebody hug and hit you up
and say they want to advertise you know
their grandfather's produce company on
your podcast for 40 bucks a month oh
yeah
that's when I say no way but yeah you
gotta need more doodads man you should
guys should get that uh you know get a
second place trophy or get little notes
you two sit up on here on a shelf all
day I mean you know he ain't [ __ ]
there in there except dude you we all
know good and well that all the notes he
is is really a stem cell carrier for
Chris
and it was a solid move you get a thick
guy you know he's out of the Midwest or
Florida which is really just a [ __ ]
dirty little cold a sack of the Midwest
and uh think about the things that
happened in Florida um crime sunburn
dude imagine you're sunburned and
somebody [ __ ] murder you gonna hurt
more did you get shot when your sunburn
hurts way more than just getting shot
and that's where the know she is and
that guys is a little stem cell just a
[ __ ] tall petri dish for Delia but a
beautiful guy though big you know good
guy is you know nice text me something
nice the other data is out of the blue
so you know I'm happy to see him every
now and then and then they got that
handsome guy now is that you know that
little [ __ ] hit man [ __ ] hot Zachary
and that guy is Italian Arabian who even
knows dude that guy [ __ ] beautiful
dude he grows his sideburns long out
[ __ ] him
you know I mean you'll find a [ __ ] on
that guy he's that hot I mean he's that
kind of hot you feel around him enough
you'll find that virgin you know
you'll find that badge on you know what
I'm saying boy let me hit this
no and that's somebody trapped in a
[ __ ] wish and well listen again Wow
it's crazy when you have sound on your
sound board of other people struggling
bro
absolutely insane alright let's go to a
segment man what I like to talk about
today is what I like to talk about today
is Robin Hood Robin Hood is an investing
app that lets you buy and sell stocks
ETFs options and Kryptos all
commissioned free while other brokerages
charge up to $10 for every trade Robin
Hood doesn't charge any Commission fees
so you can trade stocks and keep all
your profits plus there is no account
minimum deposit needed needed to get
started so you can start investing at
any level the simple intuitive design of
robin hood makes investing easy for
newcomers and experts alike view easy to
understand charts and market data and
place a trade in just four taps on your
smartphone you can also view stock
collections such as 100 most popular
with robin hood you can learn how to
invest in the marketplace as you build
your portfolio discover new stocks track
your favorite companies and get custom
notifications for price movements so you
never miss the right moment to invest
robin hood is giving listeners of
congratulations a free stock like apple
ford or sprint to help you build your
portfolio
sign up at congrats dot robin hood
dot-com man i wonder what it's like to
be crystal lee a man alright yeah look
guys if you don't [ __ ] listen to the
podcast ain't you know what the [ __ ] I'm
saying dude what I want to tell you
today guys is about the cash app
download the cash app for free on the
App Store or Google Play market you got
the cash up right here okay what I want
to tell you guys oh sorry
what I want to tell you little babies
you little infants you little zygotes
you little second trimester bad boys and
girls this podcast is brought to you by
the cash app the app for righteous
sisters scrumptious twinks beautiful
zygotes downright dogs scaley skittles
scary hookers and warm senior citizens
the cash app you want cash
ye [ __ ] got it cuz I do but get the
app anyway look like you have [ __ ]
cash even though Danny the cash app this
podcast brought you by the cash at man
it's hard being Chris D'Elia that's one
thing I learned really I think today is
that dude it's hard imagine when you get
up how tall you are
like I get up at a reunify vallevan six
feet you know if I've been doing yoga
you get up as Chris D'Elia you got a
[ __ ] really get a hop you know you
got to get close imagine being closer to
the lights and the ceiling and just
feeling that pressure constantly imagine
going outside and you [ __ ] know a
little more because you could see a
little further and the pressure that
that brings into you you know it's crazy
imagine ringing sixty ice coffees a day
and then trying to go to sleep after you
and I couldn't do it that's Chris D'Elia
imagine getting a [ __ ] bad tattoo
even though you said tattoos were for
[ __ ] boys
for decades and also you got a fire on
your arm and it looks like and you got
it right during the Malibu fires which I
thought was very [ __ ] up while your
friends burn you [ __ ] get a little
flame on your wrist bro you know it
looks like an Applebee's commercial do
it if you've seen it when they cook
something real fast and also I'll save
this about Applebee's they don't even
have a grill in the back they got some
microwaves and charcoal food paint man
so don't be [ __ ] screwed over that's
that [ __ ] I don't like
yes sir Spanish what I'm saying is this
man
it's hard being Chris D'Elia I thought
it'd be easier oh yeah and I wet the bed
all about 28 did I'll tell you this one
time this is pretty unfortunate but it's
also what happened is um you know this
girlfriend that I had for about two
years or a year and a half even though
we were both cheating on each other and
we didn't even really like each other
that much and I had a lot of sexual -
you know issues going on but we she
slept over one night at my buddy's was
sucked on buddy's couch and I urinated
you know cuz that's what I do if
somebody sleeps really close to me in a
bed I'll piss the bed and um and I peed
into this sofa cushion dude and you
could pick it up I picked it up in the
morning and literally bro I never I
didn't know the human body called a much
urine you know they say it's like nine
pints of urine or whatever and they lied
bro this was [ __ ] four quarts just
rolled out of this pillow it was almost
like doing magic it was almost like
doing magic and I still feel bad but
then we but that was the first night we
ever hung out together and she stayed
with me for about a year and a half so
I'd like to apologize to all the women
that have ever dated me and or put up
with me over the years I would like to
do that I'm glad I got that off of my
chest you know what I'm saying
good gunk yeah that's what I am when it
comes to dating what else can we talk
about one hire oh okay so Christopher
and what's Christopher's middle name
Alan that's what I heard it is so that's
interesting oh really um bro
which is obviously Alan's older brother
so Christopher will you how many slaves
did somebody in his family own bro and I
would never own a slave and I'm gonna
say that right now because I've been
getting you know some emails and [ __ ]
out no I'm not that guy dude you know
and if I did they would probably be
Asian so don't group me in with bad
people but I'm saying this is that I
joined a cult one time and I know you
guys are in a cult I've seen you at the
shows man I've seen you run up to me
with you done a month-long sweat shirts
with the [ __ ] seams coming undone you
know one got taped his together because
I fell apart the second time he wore it
but I've seen this kind of stuff going
on man and I want to say this that [ __ ]
oh yeah I joined this cult one time that
um that they had this deal is called
orgasmic meditation and the thing is you
meet up with people and it's like you
learn to touch a woman's crotch but in a
pleasurable way she not this you're not
that jouster you know I'm sayin you
ain't some [ __ ] freak get her r-n
fare down this lady's pants all the time
you know what I'm saying you know what's
goin on
and you meet up and it's all strangers
and they have coffee and then the women
will lay down and they get naked right
from the waist down it's not like a
breast deal and the man will sit there
by the woman's crotch and have on gloves
special gloves clear gloves like you see
at a cafeteria and then there's a doctor
going around the room who explains to
you how to pleasure a woman right and
it's uh it's wild you know you think
it's not going to be wild and then it's
all different ages you know so like
sometimes the woman will be 60 70 years
old and you'll be whatever old you are
and nice and then you for 15 minutes you
do this exact sort of you know kind of
about this orgasmic meditation where you
touch this woman's you know little deal
and it's like everybody's in groups so
they're all over the room there's like
20 groups of like different people and
everybody's kind of like dialed into
their partner and then when the buzzer
goes off you have to stop and uh and
yeah it's called orgasmic meditation man
and people meet up and do it all across
America and there's little clubs so I
got into it
a woman introduced me to it she told me
to go to this meet up downtown and it
was in like in the fashion district kind
of where people buy carpet and you know
suits like that are really bad but cheap
and so you had a couple dudes rollin in
in these big suits these Chinese suits
and then they partner you up they had
you know kind of a fruit plate and and
coffee and then next you know you're
partnered up and by the end of the
afternoon of this seminar you're
partnered off in this like warehouse
floor and all the women have their pants
off and all the men are like learning
how to pleasure women and it's crazy
because you can hear the lady you know
two people over [ __ ] you can tell
who's winning it's like Mario Cart like
you can definitely tell by like the
sounds people are making like who's
winning and then some lady will just
spray out across the room and you're
like who the [ __ ] is that you know and
you know you're in third place dude you
know what I'm saying you should have
picked Bowser
and so it gets really intense in there
and some guys some men kind of perv out
and they have to you know they have to
take them out of the room they have like
bouncers in there too but then you get
in this group and it's called orgasmic
meditation and you can meet people up
and just during the day you can stop
over at somebody's house and you do this
like little ritual and and that's and
women learn to feel like empowered
because they get to you know kind of do
a jack you Latorre
orgasm and men get to learn how to do it
[ __ ] I don't know what it was for honest
they didn't want to think about it but I
did it for about six months man and it's
crazy because you'd be driving in Venice
you be like oh [ __ ] there's somebody
right here you know cuz there's an app
and you could just hit them up and then
stop in and next thing you know one time
actually was up here in the Hollywood
Hills and some lady's dog [ __ ] kept
like not bothering me but definitely
made it hard you know it's hard to like
pleasure a woman when they got a little
dog right there you know
so anyway man I think we've hacking into
the surface but first man we have one
going away segment man and uh and I want
to thank all the babies and all the
beautiful babies out there and all the
you know stillborns or whatever you guys
are called I'm gonna thank all you guys
for your support and for supporting
Chris D'Elia he's a nice man and he's a
funny man and he's always been good to
me and he has a you know he has a big
long fashionable heart what do we do
here we got miss connections and these
are from New Orleans okay let's go
through a couple this one's yellow goose
this is a woman I still think about you
wet and heavy beautiful the bruised
fruit this is sounding like a couple of
sisters fighting at a [ __ ] farmers
market I wish I knew how to suck out
dance like an advertisement I'm afraid
and it shows I hope you're well
I still think damn so that sounds like a
[ __ ] drive-by shooting to me but I
don't know but if you've been in New
Orleans man it's definitely one of the
more popular outdoor sports it's
somebody going by with a gun and then
people losing their lives that's yellow
goose let's go to another one
any hung bulls left any white hung bulls
still left on here bye better looking
for next few nights possible [ __ ] scene
picks a number and that's WB white boy
so or white baby this could be a one of
the Delia's listeners Westbank
yeah that's West Bank WB and if you've
been over the West Bank man if you want
to [ __ ] hang out at a closed-down mall
you need to go to the West Bank in New
Orleans and the crazy thing about the
West Bank it's actually east of the city
so [ __ ] bootleg cartographers out
there but yeah this is a great place if
you want to meet somebody trying to [ __ ]
or and they also want to see pics first
maybe you're gonna [ __ ] somebody off
here you know I don't think you should
kid you know getting head shots first
seems a little outrageous I think but
and this was posted about six hours ago
so that was you know around around
lunchtime so that's what's happening
down there one more right here says
mommy mommy so um I'm looking for a
mommy figure I've had this type of
relationship before and I miss it I feel
I suffer from abandonment and was
abandoned yet again recently oh damn
if you're a female and may be interested
in and drop me a line um thanks you okay
so this is from Africa probably because
they're definitely that penmanship gets
really eccentric you were abandoned yet
again looking for a mommy
I think this stuff's gonna start
happening you're gonna have these mom
and like trouble boy meetups you know
you in there you're gonna you know and
this is you know a lot of even if you
stop at a rest area you see people
[ __ ] hug and they don't even know each
other and that's been happening for a
long time button it used to be men he
used to be secret men and now it is more
just young fellas you know single-parent
children who were just hugging random
women and getting that feel all right
here's one out there in the Laplace and
Kenner and shout out to my boy Billy
conforto out there from Laplace who
[ __ ] died you guys some of you guys
know him and some of y'all don't but he
ate a dude he was you know the first you
know homoerotic man I ever met in my
life and we were there together he
grilled us up a couple of cutlets and we
got so [ __ ] high and Princess Diana
died and I didn't know Princess Diana
was man I thought it was a dog that he
had and it was a Queen of England but
anyway but he passed away uh so shout
out to him and he's from Laplace
actually use a box or two and so that's
the crazy thing is this fighting a dude
cuz gay dudes first of all can [ __ ]
fight you know burn a gay guy with a
match see if you don't beat the [ __ ] out
of here
but this one says in search of the films
that Tong Tong and they got a Tong Tony
mode you dude and I'll use that tongue
emoji man that one's kind of like you
know I don't know what could happen you
know like I need to get you know I maybe
need to see a doctor might have sore I
always say they're like what does that
mean I'm like oh it means I've strep
throat if they're not like really down
in search of sexy big booty Femmes that
want to lick some GD [ __ ] and that
means god damn and I respect that you
know not me you know not using the
Lord's name in vain right there they
want to lick some GD [ __ ] no games no
fakes
don't hit me up if you're not ready to
show me what that mouth do no men at all
so this is lesbians and this is a swamp
lesbians man and you know what I'm
saying if you these [ __ ] do you know
no you won't see a lot of snakes in the
area shedding skin cuz he [ __ ] will
lick the skin right off a snake you know
these bad girls are [ __ ] these bad
girls out there the swamp lesbians man
come on they could clean a rat's back
brother no it's okay man I just I just I
don't know it's tired today man I hate
to [ __ ] come over here and be tired
but you drive over here that's so nice
in here I can't help but want to rest
dude I came in they had a butler
you know they had I'm gonna say slaves
but they had some chains in the hallway
I'm like what are these for you know
these seem real old and they had a ship
like a really old ship parked out front
I mean it's obvious that the Lee has
been dabbling in the dark arts and I'm
happy to be here in his castle in the
background but this it's intense gonna
move into another man's podcast studio
you know and Chris I think he doesn't
want skill he really has his more
confidence he goes into somewhere and
he's just a [ __ ] you know he's just a
party boy you know but I'm more that
lurker you know what I'm saying I'm the
doodle hot in your closet for two days
before I tell you I'm over there and
he's the guy will be in your [ __ ]
kitchen
[ __ ] Dayton your stepmom and
everybody's getting that [ __ ] your [ __ ]
fake black eyes on the button so but
yeah you know I'm just more a little bit
more I think call Marte you know and the
spanish calm and I'm more just a little
chill you know and I think I get over
here and also there's no doodads in here
you know they got a TV over there where
you can see yourself you know they got
to Butte you know some beautiful
producers in here
I'm sure the no cheese in here somewhere
doing something you know gardening or
something in the basement I heard the
only give him one hour of daylight a day
so but yeah I don't know man I guess
it's you know I didn't know what to
expect you know it's April Fool's and
it'd be interesting to be Chris D'Elia
for a little while and actually have
that brain in your head you know where
you just are on your phone and then it's
laugh at people for a second you know
but you love going up meals with your
friends you know and I think he's
Italian I don't [ __ ] know but he
might be Slavic you know he seems like a
guy that probably grew up in an area
where you had to see far you know or
whoever his people are from so probably
you know he could have been raised
around quicksand because you need that
extra height because you got to [ __ ]
have a chance to yell for longer fur
assistance but yeah man
this has been good dude this is April
Fool's man and I'm just an April Fool
today and I'm happy to be here on that
Chris D'Elia in that podcast studio with
the [ __ ] babies bro man very Cider
House Rules when if you guys ever seen
that but but I see a lot of babies that
some of my shows and they come up and
they wearing the [ __ ] you know and
actually brought a new shirt to that
Christmas is hella now and if you guys
have ever seen this one right here that
[ __ ] gang gang hit her right there
from dead you know so you got that
[ __ ] white hitter and this one has a
little bit of chalk on it dark choc Cole
you get that online on the Internet Theo
von comm slash store you know what I'm
saying cuz I'm gonna what is that a
handicapped parking oh that's pretty
sweet I don't know he cared about that
that's awesome man it's like a move over
dude somebody uh who got hit by a cars
here
I respect that man yeah thank you guys
for let me sit in today and you and you
guys a studio I'm curious to see what
Chris did on on our episode I'm sure
that it was so much better than this
actually but this has been a real joy
and I know his producer you know helped
out and my producer helped out and okay
so apparently you can't say a lot of
stuff around here so maybe that's why I
felt uneasy but it's crazy when you're
on the other side of the net you know
it's crazy when Thundercat you know when
you [ __ ] wake up and you're in Castle
Grayskull you know it's crazy when
you're Serina
but you wake up in [ __ ] Venus you
know and you got a couple of kids and
you can't play tennis anymore and that's
what it kind of feels like today you
know it's crazy when you [ __ ] you
know you're Hufflepuff and damn suddenly
you're Slytherin you know and you can
hear snakes in here in the hallway you
can hear them listening and as dirty
cannons in the kitchen man who has still
eyes cannons bro so what I'm saying guys
is this man be good babies I'll see you
guys in the future and thank you for
supporting live podcast of a lot of
different people and yeah this is crazy
this is this is a crazy experiment and
I'm glad that we did it and Gang Gang
man be good to yourselves cuz I bet you
guys deserve thank you
[Music]